Welcome to the Qiskit in Classrooms module
on quantum key distribution.
My name is Katie McCormick and today we're
going to explore how quantum mechanics
can help us share encryption keys securely.
First, let's talk about why we need
quantum key distribution in the first place.
In classical cryptography, two parties
who want to communicate securely
need to share a secret key that only
they know about.
The challenge is: how do you share that
key without an eavesdropper intercepting it?
This is where quantum mechanics comes in.
The BB84 protocol, developed by
Charles Bennett and Gilles Brassard in 1984,
uses the properties of quantum states
to detect any eavesdropping attempt.
The key idea is that measuring a quantum
state disturbs it. If someone tries to
intercept the quantum bits being sent
between Alice and Bob, their measurement
will introduce errors that Alice and Bob
can detect.
Let's walk through the protocol step by step.
Alice starts by preparing a sequence of qubits.
For each qubit, she randomly chooses one of
two bases: the computational basis,
which uses the states zero and one, or the
Hadamard basis, which uses plus and minus.
She then randomly assigns a bit value,
zero or one, and prepares the qubit accordingly.
Bob receives each qubit and measures it
in a randomly chosen basis as well.
After all qubits are sent, Alice and Bob
publicly compare which bases they used,
but not the results of their measurements.
When they used the same basis, their
results should match perfectly.
They keep only these matching-basis results
and discard the rest.
This gives them a shared string of bits —
the raw key.
Now here's where it gets interesting.
If an eavesdropper, Eve, tried to measure
the qubits in transit, she would have had
to guess the basis for each qubit.
About half the time, she'd guess wrong,
and her measurement would disturb the state.
Alice and Bob can detect this by comparing
a random subset of their shared key.
If they find errors, they know someone
was listening and they abort.
In this module, you'll implement this
protocol using Qiskit and see it in action.
You'll create the quantum circuits,
simulate the key exchange,
and even test what happens when
Eve tries to eavesdrop.
Let's get started!